now do you remember when we look at
simple harmonic motion we looked at this
idea which we saw okay things do this
things do this what kind of function
would give us this kind of behavior and
then we went through we differentiated
from what we resulted in and we got out
of that a differential equation a really
important differential equation which
may which define simple have ownership
they write this down but what was that
equation very support X double dot is
equal to what yeah very good- or
negative and squared X right so in other
words your acceleration is proportional
to and opposite whatever your
displacements okay so this was crucial
in the same way in projectile motion we
have a set of equations for acceleration
I have to have to why do I have to have
to because I've got two axes of motion
right and I want to think about them
separately so I want you to go right
back to our first sentence since there's
no propulsion right in projectile motion
nothing is making this go quicker I
throw it with that initial velocity okay
and then it just keeps on moving through
so what is making it faster or slower
horizontally because we're not think
about proportion we're nothing about air
resistance either which is what we slow
it down because it's running into air
because we're not thinking of anything
of that sort there is no change in the
horizontal velocity okay now this is
really interesting it's this is no
change of horizontal velocity this is
your acceleration equation horizontally
but vertically something very different
is happening right because gravity is
pulling this object back down to the
ground account and it's playing it at a
constant rate so we say because pulling
down it's a negative and then G will be
defined as one of two things basically
it'll either be 10 meters per second per
second or obey the other carbon double
you'll find is 9.8 meters per second per
second whichever they want you to do the
question will define ok but we might as
well put over here on the right-hand
side
it's usually either G equals 10 or g was
that point eight okay I think you'll
find ten much more frequently just
because it results in easier than others
okay so now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to give you a situation what to
say whether I gave me so this is going
to be example three coming up and from
here from these two and just your
initial piece of information like say
this right which is very very little
data okay I can get all six of my
equations of motion for projectile
motion okay so let's start with some
initial conditions let's say this is
example 3 you've got an object i'm going
to say just because this is our first
like proper example i'm just going to
fire it from the ground but often you'll
hear it in a fire from a height you know
it's been raised the the object that is
financed object is up high or you might
be firing from down low and try to hit
something that's at sea level or ground
level or whatever is so initially 5
humming around I'm not going to give you
all of the the words that flock that we
usually surround this they will say
someone throws a ball or a cannon fires
a shell but all of those things are the
same what really matters is the
equations of motion um and I'm going to
say at let's just go to some easy
numbers 30 meters per second 30 degrees
angle of inclination which we remember
we measure from the horizontal and let's
go with this equal number of gb 10
meters per second square okay all right
now first let's get the equations of
motion it always starts with getting
these six equations in question and
because every single projectile motion
question relies on these two ideas right
its projected so it's not getting faster
in the stall and under the force of
gravity so you just got this right I'm
always going to begin with
too and i'm going to get everything else
out of this information right let's go
with me on horizontal first so if you've
got X double dot equals 0 I want to
climb up the ladder to get to my other
horizontal equations of motion so to get
to X dot what do I have to do I'm
integrating right um I started from the
bottom in terms of the high storage so
now I'm going to go up and up and up and
when you have zero and you integrate it
you just get us just gettin close to
right now keep in mind where I'm
starting from him he's here sorry I went
here under go here and I'm gonna have to
to get to the next step I'm gonna have
to integrate again yes and it exactly
the same way after I've done with this
horizontal business I'm gonna have to
start here and if you have to integrate
again and then I'm gonna have to
integrate one more time how many
introduced is done for how many of them
a definite integrals none of them none
of them so I'm going to get four
constants of integration okay so get
ready for them to fly around be there
gonna be 4 i'm gonna call this one to
see one now at this point obviously I
want to work out this constant use
before I go any further I don't want to
have what slots flying around how do I
work out what the horizontal component
wishes yeah you see I have this on the
board right this is voters by accident I
know the initial speed there it is right
and I also know the Eagle inclination
that was projected at so i can use these
now i am going to use the formulas but
the same time i would like you to draw
the diagram it helps you number one I
understand what's going on number two
actually help you make sure you get to
the formulas right because at this
initial stage we're still not you know
you're not very familiar with them yeah
um you'll see why in a minute because uh
I mean the short of it is I want to make
sure it's oriented right at the moment
all I'm showing you is this first
instant in time but there are other
instance of time that I want to draw and
it might not be going in that nicely
direction for instance it might be
dropping which is what I'm going to have
a kind of all they don't yeah so I just
want to make sure like it's not just a
triangle hang out in the middle of
nowhere I just want to i want to show
this is a particular snapshot in instead
of time right in much the same way that
like do i need these parts of the axis
over here really like i need this shape
this is the important part and this is
just kind of fluff really but i have it
there so i have a frame of reference for
the entire object okay um it's not like
you're going to lose marks is where you
draw is a triangle but i think it's a
helpful way to do it okay right so let
me drop my box you can see I've drawing
it pretty wide because or coming on
Tommy well I'm doing pretty white
because my egg living condition is their
degrees right so it's going to be proof
wow that's my fed degrees I've got 30
meters per second here don't off at its
angle and now i'm going to work out x
dot and y dot so you can see here x la
will be V coz theta because it's this
horizontal length in this particular
case is 30 plus 30 degrees right colors
30 degrees is too so this is for 315 33
yep and exactly the same way why that's
going to be not 30 because 30 degrees
but for these sign papers it already
rehearsed sign pay that's just harsh sir
this is jobs 15 meter per second ok so
I'm going to use each of these this is
just my initial condition right so at T
equals 0
before I've progressed to the situation
I already know what the horizontal
component of motion is am start is equal
to 53 so when you compare these two
equations that constant must be 15 root
3 extra that's not so complicated so
therefore yes ok I have started with
acceleration there's predefined velocity
I integrated once what am I gonna do now
do it again ok next up with our X dot so
now finally X is going to be equal to
which makes sense because because if I
want to know the position at any time
just horizontally right I just pump in
like uh after three seconds I move that
about and remember that morsi's not
changing yes so we 15 root 3 meters the
first time and then double that the
second time and triple that folk second
etc so what am I going to do here how do
i resolve this guy yeah i'm just going
to define stuff to begin at the origin
right you don't have to define things at
the origin if it's convenient you might
like to start a bar or below zero but it
just kind of depends on the question at
T was there x equals zero so therefore
my concerts going to render out to be 0
ok that's part of the point this is a
little bit like on when you were doing
simple harmonic motion you would often
define your pic sine or cosine based on
where you were starting when would you
pick science physical home ownership
when you begin at the center of worship
when would you be cosine when you're
starting at an extreme of motion and if
you're staying somewhere between does
now in the same way here I am choosing
things such that these constants here
they end up being zero the way that you
you two sine and cosine made the phase
zero does that make sense do you think
you could get your equations for
vertical acceleration velocity and
displacement why do you have a go you're
going to start you
why not because we define G to be 10
we're going to write minus 10 why don't
you have a go see if I yeah